[Music]
this Valentine's Day revisit the film
that reminds you that no matter how much
you love each other
you're both gonna grow old and die the
notebook from sappy Arthur Nicholas
Sparks comes the timeless romance that
paved the way for millions of people to
form unrealistic expectations of their
real-life relationships meet Ally an
attractive wealthy southern belle whose
biggest problem is that everyone adores
her meet Noah a poor country boy whose
entire family is dead when these two
find each other
he'll criticize her for being a pushover
and then constantly tell her what to do
and she will abandon him on numerous
occasions together they'll be so
indecisive you'll wonder why they're
even trying I hate you I hate you I love
him now I hate you I need you to tell
him that I love him if you leave here I
hate you do you guys love each other
well that's what we do I love that
taught an entire generation of women
that it's perfectly okay to string along
a sweet handsome supportive guy as long
as you're able to satisfy your every
impulsive desire okay should I be
worried
no I don't think our movie so generic
yet inexplicably popular it's basically
the Olive Garden of love stories and a
romance that will make nagging
girlfriends ask why aren't you more like
Ryan Gosling prompting all boyfriends to
ask can we please just watch die hard
there to relive the bad driving
the violence the shirtlessness the red
dresses the more shirtlessness the
horrible slurping and the death of
feminism starring perfection rachel
mcadams Apple Newsies Julia Stiles
Joseph Stalin fancy Cyclops James
garnish and an old lady the movie your
girlfriend will make you watch so wait
he wrote hundreds of letters but
couldn't just call her once ah
could have saved me two hours thanks for
watching be sure to subscribe and tell
us in the comments below what movie you
want to see next and tell me what word
you'd like to hear me say in my epic
movie trailer boys to infinity and
beyond
friendship is magic I am the eggman whoo
go goo joob giggity giggity giggity goo